[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados cómo llego ucrania a
convertirse en un campo de guerra
ucrania y rusia comparten profundos
lazos históricos ambas naciones
reivindican su origen en la luz de kiev
de la era medieval y el territorio
ucraniano formó parte de la unión
soviética como la república socialista
soviética de ucrania antes de
independizarse lo hizo en 1991 cuando la
urss se desintegró este año la población
votó en un referendo en el que el 90%
apoyó la independencia en
1994 que accedió a renunciar a su
arsenal nuclear el tercero más grande
del mundo entregando sus ojivas a moscú
a cambio de que los países firmantes
entre ellos rusia se comprometieran a
respetar su soberanía en lo que se llamó
el memorando de budapest desde 1994
hasta 2004 leonid kuchmá presidio el
país su gobierno e inició una transición
hacia una sociedad capitalista desde
entonces y en los años venideros los
gobiernos ucranianos oscilaron entre los
intereses de rusia y los de occidente en
2004 el candidato prorruso víctor
yanukóvich ganó unas elecciones
manchadas por irregularidades y las
denuncias de fraude desencadenaron en
protestas fue la llamada 'revolución
naranja' que llevó a miles de ucranianos
a las calles lo que forzó la repetición
de las elecciones y el pro europeísta
víctor yúschenko fue declarado ganador
yúschenko prometió entonces sacar a
ucrania de la órbita del kremlin y
encaminar al país hacia la unión europea
y la otan pero la entrada de ucrania a
la otan siempre fue una línea roja para
moscú que temió que la alianza se
extendiera hacia sus fronteras en lo que
se considera el primer enfrentamiento
verbal de rusia contra la otan en la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich del
2007 vladimir putin condenó los
esfuerzos de eeuu a la cabeza de la
alianza por construir un mundo en el que
predominarán solamente sus intereses y
las cosas empeoraron en 2008 cuando la
otan en dio la bienvenida a las acciones
de ucrania y a georgia a sumarse al
tratado militar en 2010 de yanukóvich se
convirtió en presidente y la crisis
estalló en 2013 cuando rechazó un
acuerdo para la asociación comercial de
ucrania con la unión europea para
estrechar lazos con rusia estallaron
protestas masivas por parte de los pro
europeos las manifestaciones conocidas
como el euro maidán continuaron en 2014
y fueron brutalmente reprimidas dejando
decenas de manifestantes muertos en
febrero de ese año el presidente ya no
cúbico huyó del país y el parlamento
votó por destituirlo e instaurar un
gobierno de facto pero europeísta rusia
y sus partidarios en ucrania denunciaron
la intervención extranjera en particular
de eeuu y hoy en día aún califican al
euro maidán como un golpe de estado en
ese contexto en marzo de 2014 rusia
anexionó a la península de crimea este
territorio mayoritariamente rusohablante
había sido cedido por moscú en la época
soviética ucrania la anexión fue
considerada por la unión europea y eeuu
ucrania por su parte denunció una
violación del memorando de budapest y
rusia alegó que radicales extremistas
habían tomado el gobierno ucraniano y
aseguró que había intervenido para
proteger a los ciudadanos rusos
residentes de crimea desde entonces
putin acusó a los opositores que tomaron
el poder en kiev de emplear técnicas
nazis sin embargo aunque si existe un
movimiento fuerte de extrema derecha en
ucrania y éste formó parte del euro-
maidán esta no era la mayoría un poco
después separatistas de donnie steele
lugansk autoproclamaron repúblicas
populares independientes desatando una
guerra contra el ejército ucraniano que
en menos de ocho años se ha cobrado la
vida de 14 mil personas occidente de que
acusan a moscú de haber armado a los
secesionistas algo que el kremlin niega
en los años venideros tras negociaciones
los llamados acuerdos de minsk
establecieron una reforma para otorgar
más autonomía a esta región conocida
conjuntamente como el donbass pero los
pactos fracasaron y los mates continuar
en abril de 2021 el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski pidió acelerar el
ingreso del país a lautaro sus pedidos
encendieron las alarmas en moscú y a
finales de 2021 vladimir putin exigió a
eeuu y la otan que se garantizará que
ucrania jamás entraría a la alianza
militar y que ésta retiraría su
armamento pesado de europa del este pero
esto no sucedió y el kremlin dijo que
sus argumentos fueron ignorados y el 21
de febrero de 2022 moscú reconoció la
soberanía de dónetsk y lugar y tres días
más tarde inició la invasión a la que
putin llama una operación militar
especial lo hace con el argumento
propagandístico de que busca
desmilitarizar y desclasificar ucrania
sin embargo la ofensiva no se limitó a
estos territorios la guerra se ha
extendido a todo el país con ataques
contra la población e infraestructura
civil o ejecuciones y otros abusos como
los denunciados en lucha y en bordj acá
el mes y medio del conflicto más de 11
millones de personas tuvieron que
abandonar sus hogares
de cuatro millones seiscientos mil de
ellas en calidad de refugiados ante un
panorama diplomático estancado no está
claro cuánto durará esta guerra si le
sirvió el vídeo para entender la
trayectoria de ucrania en su corta
independencia los esperamos en otro
episodio de en cinco minutos en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]